[Music]
very interesting part of the world that
was here 16 years ago I remember it
being quite wild at that time well today
zero plans zero agenda zero people that
I know just want to get into what we can
[Music]
unless I'm missing something I don't
think Bishkek is a mourning place I
can't say there's a a rush hour feel to
the streets it's a beautiful setting the
city sits at the base of the ala two
mountains part of the Tian Shan range
and they just rip out of the city up to
roughly 5,000 meters 16,000 feet very
cool so they have these soda machines
Cola yeah pear juice
instead of it
slaughtered a couple tools are a couple
occasions wah-wah
you see pick up these scales to breathe
the way yourself
yeah the streets
[Music]
an old circus here I don't know if it's
still an operation or not this old
Soviet architecture is very fascinating
and you can see it's crumbling and well
the water fountains aren't functioning
it's very creative you got to look
beyond the building materials the
building materials work we're mostly
that they used with actual design
the lines to form super interesting see
these porthole windows sort of some art
deco style Bishkek so far has been this
place that well there's a there's a
strong strong feeling of the Soviet past
with the architecture there's a lot of
new stuff going up look at this look at
this beautiful so cool and then you got
this over here new construction that one
looks halted
trust you too
I don't know about the street cops but
the the traffic cops are super corrupt
on our trip into Bishkek yesterday
stopping like speed traps everywhere
stopping people for from what I've been
told not even going over the speed limit
looking for bribes and well that's how
it works so out of the world but these
guys in the streets I don't I don't
think are that way I'm not sure that
guys I usually don't do this in my
videos but I'm running into nobody today
so we're gonna go into the National
Library interesting-looking building
wow this is cool this is really
interesting
[Music]
okay Tom so I need a register to enter
the library yes it's all okay so like 15
cents Hilton Hotel de Gaston Itza
okay well Luke's up okay okay spasiba
registration for the library check this
out this is so cool like a step back in
time
spasiba mr. Ravi quite often in these
Sylvia these old Soviet type places the
camera has a big no now she saw me with
the camera just give me a stroke
upstairs love it or hate it
this old Soviet stylist well quite
extreme quite heavy
there's something really common
Rossiter
some Saudi influence that Saudi Arabia
Kyrgyzstan okay she's coming camera down
so she's coming you know what I haven't
seen yet box where the box
Oh Thomas odd convenient
[Music]
well guys I hope that was interesting
it's interesting as a library can be on
video it definitely takes the Lord for
the strangers library but the most
interesting for sure
on with the discovery I gotta meet
people now I gotta find some young
English speakers I can tell me about
Bishkek because I don't know about
this city to be honest so I'm gonna get
my bag and we'll go hit the streets
that's for dunya Superboy
nice people shot pooja step not sure
spasiba Plus dad throats and coffee shop
with private rooms very romantic stylish
Holly Han is my young waiter here he's
fantastic crew Tolly Han very cool guy
very cool staff here very nice people
what's your name Kwan HP travel a lot of
pop culture stuff Peter Griffin who's
that oh did find a Family Guy
I've actually seen that show once
spasibo vacherin
[Music]
the interesting thing is a lot of the
Kyrgyz especially the woman they sort of
take on this European body language they
have an Asian look but their body
language the way they approach you just
the way they handle themselves it's much
more Russian or European than what I
think of Chinese Japanese or Thai when
you look at a map you'll see China isn't
far away Afghanistan Pakistan to the
south to the north you have Kazakhstan
and Russia so it's in this very
interesting center point between a lot
of history and world powers so you see
all of these influences you see a lot of
rousseff occation in the architecture
and in the way the city set up and in
some of the culture and then on the flip
side I went to the OSH bazaar and that's
where you feel that Central Asian or
Asian trading merchant vibe standing
outside the OSH lozad and I was told
this is a very interesting bazaar
I don't know it's the biggest but one of
the biggest in the city and it's also
rice with pig poppers so let's check
this out
[Music]
Supermarket
and so in this part of the world a lot
of people do all their shopping at these
bazaars cuz you can get absolutely
everything you get all your food get
your clothes get your home repair stuff
they're also like shopping modern
shopping malls here a bit of everything
actually and you know I think the
wealthier people are probably not
shopping in these places this is someone
correct me in the comments if I'm wrong
but this is where you get the best the
best of values when you're buying things
here and I believe it's a bargaining
culture believe you can bargain on a lot
of this stuff
[Music]
oh this side the side is yours of the
shop nice is hers okay
is this expensive these stores to rent
it is how much to rent this may be
expensive it's amazing yeah yeah it's
good business
her little place was roughly 750 dollars
and it was about the size of these so
this place is absolutely massive
and the fact that each one of these say
each one goes for 750 that one's a lot
bigger
Wow there's this market for those that
are the the landlords
[Music]
[Applause]
escape I love it it's really cool city
it's really quite interesting for me
it's like nothing else so every person
every counters person yep uh-huh
wait would yeah yeah yeah true every
country's people are very good mm-hmm
yes politics is usually the problem
right yeah yeah Kyrgyzstan has very
close ties to Russia and every X Soviet
republic is a bit different in this
respect in Bishkek do more people speak
Russian on the street or more people
speak curious now Russian what about you
well you're mainly person now English
language do you wanna yeah yeah
let's talk you sign the roster check it
out
I want to go to the square and then
we'll go to the cederberg I like your
flag I was told the it's the Sun and
then it's the Thatcher's to a yurt right
it's like a structure to the Arabs
what's what's going on with this statue
here Monica Minaj Munoz would not exist
expensive sweater very cool especially
this time of day everyone comes out so I
met these young students who started a
Reading Club every day sit on the steps
and read and they're super proud of
reading together which is so cool and
how many places in the world in 2019
do you see teenagers and young
20-somethings sitting together in
reading in silence without any devices
Nicole goes Republic is better reader
country is it what country either in
front you guys read a lot yeah the
future will be a leading point how do
you feel about carrying a Senate freedom
you feel freedom yeah you're like a real
follow country and we believe that we
have a good future we believe that our
opportunity generation can change our
country our counts with democracy but
you are not taught our democracy that's
why we're going to make our country so
everyone should know their own rights
most of the people o people back out of
the Sabbatini and they don't know their
own rights even teenagers don't know
their own right so you are gonna change
the teenagers side
it's very impressive like it's super
cool thanks grass three
[Music]
do people stick to Tony Hawk